well today we have the pleasure of
listening to Professor Aaron lavich
who's one of the newest and I would like
to say one of the coolest scientists
that are here at Yale
Aaron received her bachelor's master's
and doctoral degree at MIT in material
science and she decided that she
actually wanted to do something more
medically oriented so she did a project
as a postdoc that is aligned with
whether her research is today what she's
interested in it has been motivated by
the fact that there's over 10,000 spinal
cord injured injuries each year and so
she seeks to create polymer scaffolds to
promote repair of smart spinal cords now
this work has been recognized highly in
2003 MIT Technology Review magazine
cited Aaron as one of the top 100 young
innovators under 35 and last year Wired
magazine indicated that Aaron was one of
the leading thinkers and doers so make
sure you get her autograph before you
leave one of the things that I think is
particularly cool about Aaron is not
only is she is a great scientist but
she's also a playwright and her plays
have been produced both in LA and in New
York so this morning please help me in
welcoming welcoming professor lavich to
the podium
put that out of the way all right well
thank you very much it's a real treat to
get to do this it's a little early for
me on Saturday morning I'm usually I'm
still curled up drinking coffee
somewhere so we'll sort of continue that
theme while talking before I really get
started we have to thank Aneesa because
she's the reason this is all happening
she's done all the legwork to really
make this happen
and it should also be noted that I got
this you know cute little award a
hundred people innovators and all that
hoopla Aneesa was one of the other
hundred people so before we get started
so this morning we're going to talk
about tissue engineering growing organs
in a dish and before we get started with
the real science behind it
I have to tell you that this is probably
one of the most interdisciplinary fields
around and I've had a lot of wonderful
collaborators who've made this work
possible now in order to do this work
you need things like antibodies so you
can actually see what's going on in the
tissue and those were gifts of some of
my collaborators there's a group of
Scandinavians that are involved in this
work we do a lot of our work actually in
pigs to see whether or not the tissue is
being recapitulated properly the
Scandinavians are very good at that
the young lab is the collab that I
collaborate with to do retinal research
the Langer lab is the lab that I came
from Bob Langer really is one of the
founders of this field
Micra collaborated at Children's
Hospital and the most important thing on
the slide is that I now have this
absolutely wonderful lab right here that
really makes this work possible and I
should have pointed out that Noah here
is in my lab and he is phenomenal and
he's actually going to be doing the
demos today so why do we have to show
engineering how did this field actually
start well it started because surgeons
are phenomenal they've learned how to
transplant an awful lot of tissues but
we don't have enough tissues for
transplantation just a couple numbers to
give you a sense of this in 2000 7,200
72,000 people were on the list with
end-stage organ failure but they're only
23,000 transplants and that's because of
shortage of tissue and tissue that
matches the transplant recipient we
learned we thought maybe we could just
put cells in the place of an organ and
maybe would actually recapitulate the
organ and people tried that and turns
out in large defects so unless you have
a very small
injury that's not true you really need
something else and so they came up with
this idea of maybe we need scaffolding
so that the cells can build new tissue
so tissue engineering basically involves
taking some sort of cells combining them
with some kind of scaffolding to give
them some sort of structure and growing
those two together so that you hopefully
have what they call a neo tissue which
you can then transplant now this makes
sense this concept of scaffolding we use
it when we build buildings all the time
and if you look at this you can see you
put up scaffolding you start to build
your building this is actually a Stata
Center I have this photo because my
parking space when I was at MIT was
overlooking the construction it was one
of the coolest things about the parking
space I hacked it was quite a schlep
from my lab but we got to actually see
this neat building the Gehry designed
going up and so they put up the
scaffolding and build these crazy
buildings and then the scaffolding goes
away and that's actually a really
important part tissue engineering that
when you use a scaffold to help direct
the cells to make a tissue you want the
scaffold to get out of the way when
you're done and you can make lots and
lots of different kinds of scaffolds
these are some of the examples of ones
that we use in tissue engineering and
these are all polymers and we'll talk a
little bit about what polymers are but
these are things that we can put in the
body and they'll actually dissolve away
as tissues repaired so you can have
things that involve lots of fibers or
sort of these big porous structures you
can have oriented structures you can
have all sorts of weird architectures
and the architecture of the scaffold
it's going to be very important to the
way the tissue forms so polymers the
things that we're actually going to be
making these scaffolds out of what are
they first off and when it's very easy
to start talking you know all polymers
they do all these things plastics
they'll save the world for anyone who's
familiar with the film The Graduate the
guy tells him to go into plastics well I
saw that film and followed suit and
actually did go into plastics plastics
are a kind of polymer and basically what
polymers are is they have building
blocks which are small molecules and
those molecules get linked together and
the way that they're linked together
controls the properties so polymers in
the end are actually huge huge molecules
if my laptop here was a single molecule
was a single part of a polymer one of
those building blocks the actual polymer
chain that we build for a normal polymer
would more than fill this room it would
be enormous
we can do some neat things with these
polymers so some of the polymers that we
actually use in tissue engineering some
of the original ones are based on things
like gelatin and gelatin is basically
jello that's a commercial form of
gelatin that you see all the time so I
snarf to this off the jello website
there they have lots of cool pictures
but actually it turns out that gelatin
is a really good scaffold and some
natural material your body actually
makes basically a collagen gel is what
we call it which is gelatin and it turns
out cells will grow on it and they'll do
some neat things but you all have played
with jello you know it's sort of you
know what's the commercial soft and
squishy well we can't always get it to
be strong enough to make the kinds of
tissues we want so there's some other
materials that we can use and these are
the building blocks we have something
called poly lactic acid and for any of
you that have ever gone running and
you've talked about lactic acid building
up in your muscles well lactic acid
there's a natural product in your body
we can make a polymer then of that
lactic acid it turns out that's a useful
thing for tissue engineering we take
these polymers they're nice and stiff we
can use them to make scaffolds and then
there's a sister material poly glycolic
acid that's essentially identical to
that and the neat things about those
polymers is that they can dissolve when
they're implanted in the body and those
small molecules those lactic acid
molecules and those glycolic acid
molecules are things our body knows how
to process so as it dissolved our body
can get rid of the products which is
really important another polymer that
was used a lot in a tissue engineering
was actually nylon and nylon is in fact
based on a natural material nylon is an
attempt to make synthetic silk it's a
hugely successful one
it doesn't degrade very readily in the
body but nonetheless you can make some
neat things out of it so people started
working with that before they were able
to make degradable versions of nylon and
my student here Noah will show you
actually how to make nylon now nylon has
a really neat history to it much neater
than a lot of other polymers which is
the other fun thing about it so nylon
consists of two components so it has
this one component that has a little
chlorine on it that's not coming out
well in another component these two ends
react with each other
and you basically get a structure that
has alternating parts to it so if you
put those two components together in a
way so that they don't interact until
they get to what we call this interface
here they'll actually get to the
interface and will start to react with
each other to form a polymer and the
polymer becomes a barrier so you
basically get the polymer at the
interface and nowhere else in the
solution and what happens is as you pull
out that interface you get a rope and
it's a really neat reaction this was
actually developed in 1935 and what was
happening was we were having trouble
getting silk from the Far East and so
people started saying well maybe we need
to really be able to make so because we
have issues we know that we're having
political tension in the world there's
some chance we may need to be able to do
things like go to war and we're going to
need things like parachutes and
parachutes were made out of silk if we
didn't have silk we couldn't make
parachutes we're gonna have a real
problem so there was a huge push at
DuPont to figure out how do we make
synthetic silk and nylon was the outcome
of that it was actually done by a man
named Carruthers he's probably the most
brilliant man ever to really step foot
in Dupont at least in my mind he
developed the synthetic rubber he
developed synthetic silk it's arguable
but nonetheless he developed synthetic
rubber and synthetic silk back when we
didn't even really understand what a
polymer even was he really laid out a
lot of the important chemistry that we
now use you ready to go through now all
right so Noah is actually going to do
the nylon rope trick so now we have the
polymer formed at the interface and as
he pulls it out more polymer reformed at
the interface
so one of the interesting things is
these molecules are in solution until
they form the polymer which isn't
soluble that's why it starts to form
that interface and come out of solution
there's a lot of little molecules in
that small beaker so now is going to be
doing this for some time actually I
don't think he's fully gathered this is
why I'm having Noah do this I can stand
here sipping my coffee in a nice relaxed
Saturday morning kind of way so we're
actually using and I'm going to check
which solvents were actually using in
this thank you so we've got let's see
what is the actual solution we snarf to
this because we repeat so this is
actually hexa methyl dice sorry hexa I'm
really going blind this morning hexamine
diamine and then we've got it in sodium
hydroxide and distilled water which is
pretty common to use water is the major
solution and then you add a little bit
of face to help the reaction go and also
there's when the reaction goes there's
chlorine on the one component and
there's hydrogen on the other that react
so you get a little bit of acid so by
having the base in there that gets the
acid out of solution so the reaction
doesn't stop and then the other one is
basically the acid and I believe it's in
methylene chloride so you pick two
components the solvents or the things
that the small molecules are soluble in
that aren't soluble in each other so you
basically set up an interface by doing
that so we have water on the bottom and
then we have an organic solvent that's
insoluble with the water on the top you
know you can actually if you want to
stop and do that afterwards for people
it should be just fine the way it is so
you guys can come up afterwards and see
is that so and you can actually come up
afterwards and see a nylon getting made
but that gives you the idea of what's
going on with it so polymers it turns
out besides being useful for scaffolds
in general are really neat things we can
play with the properties pretty
intensively and one of the things we can
do with them is that these polymers of
these long chains right they're like
spaghetti and usually when you just have
the polymer sitting there all of the
chains are not
up like spaghetti well if you take that
polymer and you stretch it those chains
the spaghetti lines start to line up
with each other but it's not really
happy being stretched out like that so
you can take it and stretch it and let
it cool down so it's stuck like that but
if you heat it up again so those chains
can move they're gonna want to go back
to that messy spaghetti sense it's just
like your room when you're cleaning your
room it doesn't stay clean for very long
it likes to get messy again and that
messiness is what's driving polymers
with a lot of their neat properties so
there was a cool paper done by Bob
Langer and ondrea's linden linden line
and what they actually did was they took
a polymer and they made it into fibers
and then they stretched out and cooled
it and when they heated it up the
polymer actually started to tie itself
because as it contracted it formed a
knot and they actually used that now for
suture material in the way it heats up
as the body is warmer than room
temperature room temperature is about 27
25 degrees Celsius depending on where
you live your body is at 37 degrees
Celsius so it heats up when it goes in
the body and it ties knots this is
brilliant for surgeons they don't have
to sit there tying complex knots they
just put the suture material in and it
also means that you can make scaffolds
with this that when they get into the
body they change their shape for
instance they could be very small but
then when you insert them into the body
they expand and fill out the area inside
of the defect so just to give you a
sense of how these polymers can really
go through some changes when you heat
them up one of the things we have here
is you know pretty classic it's just a
soda bottle in fact I think we cheated
and we're using a water bottle because
it turns out it's a little bit thinner
and this polymer has been stretched out
which was formed into this bottle so
Noah is going to heat it up and we're
gonna show you what it was like before
it got stretched out and stuck like this
area
again this is why I know it's doing this
so I can stand over here in a nice
relaxed way
so you can see this bottle starting to
shrink and in fact pretty soon the label
will pretty much fall off so it'll just
keep getting smaller and smaller and
smaller the original form it's actually
a very tiny little piece of polymer that
they blow up into the large bottle form
that you're used to seeing you can you
need a really powerful hairdryer I don't
think most of the hairdryer I know will
actually get hot enough but you can do
it in boiling water so you can actually
take if you're careful take a nice big
you know pot that you would normally
make spaghetti in and put a bottle in it
and it will actually do the same thing
about it once the water set that rolling
boil that's a good hundred degrees C and
that's hot enough to make it contract
uh-huh the so you mean like the
polystyrene ones the foamy ones they're
also polymers they probably won't go to
its nice a shape because they use a
foaming process to make them you used to
be able to do it really well with
margarine tubs because they would go
back actually to a cube is what they
were because they were pressed out and
then they were expanded the problem with
margarine tubs now is they decided to
make them dishwasher safe so it's really
hard to get them hot enough to get them
to go back to that we tried that in the
lab and it turns out they burn before
you actually get to the point of getting
them back to the original shape we had
fun actually experimenting with which
things we could do this with so we do
this now with this because it's faster
but you can do the same thing with
boiling water at home you can it's if
you wanted to yeah you could and
actually back when I was a grad student
when we were sort of playing around with
different materials to make things we
would often for instance start with just
polystyrene containers and melt them
down and remould them to something that
we were using
traditionally this I mean this would be
an obvious way to recycle right that you
can shrink these things down and then
reuse them the problem is that a lot of
times there's additives that end up
getting mixed in during the process and
people who make bottles and other
products are very concerned that those
additives will affect their bottle I
mean the last thing you want is a soda
bottle
that first spontaneously and that tends
to be why recycling hasn't caught on
quite as much it's not cheap enough for
them to worry about the risk of having
impurities in their system so um know it
you can stop if you want or you can just
keep going so no it's clearly enjoying
the tank uh-huh so that's one of the
cool things about this the bottle
maintains its shape basically until the
end it'll basically shrink down and what
happens is when they when they make
these bottles since they basically make
a little one and expand until it's
bigger so ultimately it'll stop looking
like a bottle will stop having that sort
of empty space inside but in the
beginning you'll still have essentially
a smaller bottle so and again it works
really nicely in the boiling water
because it's so uniform the way it heats
it up where is no no while he's very
good with his hairdryer is probably
slightly less uniform than the boiling
water so what they actually do is it's
an injection molding process so they
squirt molten polymer into a mold and
then they actually have a blower that
blows through the mold and inflates it
so if they call it bottle forming but
basically it's like blowing up a balloon
and once it gets blown up they cool it
down very quickly so it can't go back
into its original shape so it freezes
that polymer in that structure thanks
Noah
so we're gonna move on to the polymers
these polymers are all great and there's
neat things we can do with them but
again they don't necessarily dissolve in
the body so we've come up with some
polymers that do dissolve in the body
and these are based on basically things
your body can metabolize and you'll
notice a theme among all of these
polymers is that they all have the same
structure they all have a carbon and
oxygen ask oxygen this is an ester group
and it's these esters that get broken
down they get attacked in the body by
water in your body so you can see these
guys all have the same ester groups up
there and actually having your polymer
break down by water is really useful
because we all have water in our body
and hopefully all we all have relatively
similar amounts you can get polymers to
break down by enzymes in your body and
that can be useful too but the downside
of that sometimes is people have
different concentrations of enzymes so
you can't necessarily count on a
particular structure building down in
the same way now one of the cool games
you can play if you do do the enzyme
breakdown technique is that if your
tissue as it grows up makes enzymes that
break down the scaffold you can
basically have a very active material
that breaks down as the tissue forms in
a really tightly controlled way the
chemistry for doing that is tricky but
it's starting to be done now because
people are realizing for certain tissues
you need the structure to be
mechanically strong and so you need the
scaffold to be strong until the tissue
is strong and that's a way to link the
two so we have all these polymers we can
play some games with them how do we
actually go ahead and make a scaffold
probably the easiest way to do it is
this process called salt leaching and
for those of you that think science is
you know hard and complex in all honesty
most of it is very simple stuff and salt
leaching is a good example of this you
start out with a polymer solution so we
take our polymer this can be these
degradable polymers and we dissolve them
in a solvent and what it means when we
dissolve it is those long molecules stay
as long molecules but they now get
separated from each other so we end up
with a solution it's just like sugar and
water or salt and water except for
instead of being sugar salt it's big
long chains and we pour that solution
then over salt and so this is this good
old fashioned rock salt something you
sitting in your house what we do the one
trick we play is that we sieve the salt
so we get salt where the particles are
all the same size we pour the solution
over the salt and we let that solvent
evaporate and that leaves behind a block
of polymer with salt crystals sitting in
it we can then just get rid of the salt
by soaking this thing in water that's
all we do we soak it in water we know
that salt is soluble in water our
polymer is not soluble in water so the
salt dissolves and it leaves behind a
polymer with pores in it and the pores
are exactly what the salt was and this
is actually pictures of that so this is
a sponge that we made in my laboratory
so it's a relatively thin disc and has
lots of pores in it you can see through
it and those pores were created by the
salt and we then went ahead and put this
in a scanning electron microscope so
that we could look at high-resolution
and really see what the architecture of
the scaffold is and so this is the
scanning electron micrograph basically a
photo and the microscope of it and you
remember if you've looked at salt you
know that it's cubic you know if you
look at little table salt it's always
these little tiny cubes and so our pores
are also cubic so you can kind of see
that nice square structure there so we
can make scaffolds we can do a whole
bunch of techniques this is just one
technique that we use in the lab to make
a scaffold it turns out you can do some
pretty neat things just with this simple
technique the one thing you don't get
typically using this technique is you
don't typically get for instance long
channels it's hard to get the salt to
line up so we've developed a few other
techniques to get different
architectures like those ones you saw
way back in the first slide but
nonetheless if we want to make a
scaffold with an architecture we're
pretty much at the point where we can do
that so the next question is we need
cells the whole point of making a tissue
is you take the scaffold you put on the
cells and hopefully make a tissue and
what cells are we going to use so for
some tissues we can use autologous cells
and that means that we use cells from
the host a good example of this is
cartilage if we want to make a new piece
of cartilage and for those of you with
achy knees this is probably sounding
really good right now we can take a
scaffold we can take a little biopsy of
your cartilage and actually they usually
do the biopsy from right behind the ear
we can put those cells we can expand
them because they tend to pull if rate
we can get them to divide so we can get
those cells to divide on our scaffold
and now we can have a scaffold with
cells that we can re implant-- in your
knee and help you with you those of you
who may have gotten rid of all your
cartilage through all those years of
running sometimes though you don't have
cells that we can harvest for whatever
reason in which case we can start to
think about getting cells from a donor
so we can actually then just like a
transplant where you train instead of
transplant in a whole organ we can
isolate those cells from that Oregon and
grow those cells up on the scaffold and
Transplant it now there are people that
are trying to look at actually
transplanted cells not from a human
problem but from a different species and
that may be one option for getting cells
right now that doesn't exist but that is
something that scientists are looking at
but there are cases where you don't have
cells that we can expand and a pretty
classic one that I work in is neural
cells you probably have heard at some
point that neural cells don't divide
when you have a nerve cell that's pretty
much it there may be a few cells that
divide but probably not a lot of them in
which case people are starting to look
at things like stem cells to see is
there another way that we can get cells
that can maybe divide so this now is
that same salt leach scaffold that I
showed you before and what we've
actually done is we've covered it with
cells and actually these particular
cells are neural stem cells these are
Mouse cells that I actually worked with
in my research way back when and we're
able to basically cover our scaffolds
with them so now we have a scaffold with
cells on it so we can really make sort
of a neo tissue and the question is is
that tissue going to work can we do
something with it now that we've made
this structure so some of the tissues
that people are looking at to see if
they can really make something that's
functional are cartilage and in theory
that's probably the easiest tissue to
make because cartilage doesn't really
have a vascular supply you don't really
have a lot of blood vessels so you don't
in theory
need to worry about getting lots and
lots of blood vessels in the structure
so you can just take the cartilage cells
put them on a scaffold and implant them
that certainly was the thought it turns
out it's a lot harder to do than that
but people are still working on it
there is a product that's on the market
called Cardoso which is by Genzyme and
this doesn't actually really
involve a scaffold but what they do is
they take the cells from behind the ear
and expand them and then basically use
what's left behind in your knee and
re-inject it and that's working all
right it doesn't tend to necessarily
last forever but for a while it gives
you some relief um people are also
looking at doing things like heart
making new heart tissue and this isn't
necessarily making an entire heart at
this point but maybe making a heart
patch that could basically be put on to
help your heart function and they now
actually have scaffolds with heart cells
and heart cells are really cool cells
because they beat so you can actually
put these cells on a polymer and they'll
contract the polymer just like your
heart beats and those are starting to
become a little bit closer to reality
they're not at the point where they can
do clinical work with it
but they're at the point where they've
got this organized tissue which behaves
like a heart tissue the question is can
they make it big enough to be useful
mm-hmm so that's a really good question
in the case of cartilage they don't need
much nutrients it turns out they're not
a very what we call metabolically active
tissue in the case of a heart it's a
huge issue because your heart is
extremely metabolically active it really
needs a lot of nutrients and a lot of
transport what's been found is if the
tissue is thin enough it basically gets
transported up by diffusion but when I
say thin enough we're talking you know
half a millimeter thick which most of
you probably know your tissues are a lot
thicker than that the way your body gets
nutrients is through a vascular supply
and that is actually the Holy Grail
right now if tissue engineering is how
do we build a vascular supply into these
tissues we're trying to make and that
becomes complex because if we're trying
to make a heart tissue we not only need
to get the heart cells in the right
place but we really need to get those
vascular parts built in in the Wrights
formation so that it actually feeds that
tissue and that's why this heart tissue
isn't big enough right now to be useful
liver has a similar issue liver we can
actually get the liver cells to organize
we haven't figured out how to get them
enough nutrients to really be a
functional liver boom bone is a little
bit hard because we need it to be so
strong and that's really been the
limitation we can make new bone tissue
but typically it can't really absorb
enough weight to necessarily be
transplanted but one of the things
that's come
and this is one of the neat things about
science is in doing this we've started
to really understand how to integrate at
least implants and other structures into
bone because we're learning more about
how bone grows skin is actually one of
the ones that's been probably the most
successful and there's a bunch of
different things that have been on the
market that have actually been used as
scaffolds for skin either after burns or
after you get an injury to your skin or
an ulcer on your skin in all honesty to
give you a sense of how successful
tissue engineering is is a field every
company that started a tissue
engineering product has sort of gone
bankrupt so we have some issues and it
not surprisingly companies are a little
nervous at this point about tissue
engineering now two of the things that
you can also conceivably tissue
engineering two things that I work on so
we'll focus on those a little bit are
the retina and the spinal cord so the
retina and the spinal cord are both
parts of the nervous system and you have
some basic cells in your nervous system
you have your neurons these are the
nerve cells that carry these impulses
and they have things like axons which
are these long processes these are these
electrical wires that run through your
your spinal cord and out to your
expenditures and carry all these signals
you also have supporting cells for
instance this one which by the way just
to give you a sense of the joy of
science I actually had to sit down with
a friend and learn how to say this word
that she had to correct me about ten
times before I actually was able to say
it only get under sight it's a real fun
word to get to say and this is a neat
cell that works in your nervous system
to form insulation around those axons so
just like when you have wires at your
home you need them to be insulated so
you don't get crosstalk and you don't
get zapped your body needs insulation as
well so we have cells that make that
insulation now looking at the retina one
of the things that happens if there's
certain diseases of the retina where you
lose your photo receptors and these
photoreceptors these are the cells that
turn light into electrical signals
they're really important cells in order
for you to see your photoreceptors have
to work and so one of the interesting
things about our eyes the photoreceptors
are in the back of the eye so the retina
is along the back of your eyeball but
the photoreceptors are now at the back
of the retina so light has to get
all the way through your eye and through
your retina to the photoreceptor before
it gets turned into an electrical signal
it's probably not the smartest way to do
it but it's the way it happens so the
architecture of your retina is going to
be really important you need your
photoreceptors and you need them to be
in the right place to integrate with the
rest of the tissue and to work now we
have a cell type called a retinal
progenitor cell that we know at least in
mice can sort of form photoreceptors but
it doesn't do it very well this is one
of the big issues when you hear people
talking about things like stem cells and
how fabulous they might be we have a
long way to go before they're fabulous
because one of the issues is when we
transplant these cells most of them die
pretty much right away
in most cases and we haven't figured out
how to keep them from dying so we're not
even talking about making new tissue
right now we're talking about keeping
the cells alive long enough to even have
a chance to make new tissue but before
these cells die we've seen them a few
times form photoreceptors so we made
scaffolds like this and these are just
porous sheets where we actually have
channels running through the sheets and
the idea is that if we pour these
progenitor cells over these sheets
hopefully they'll line up just like they
line up in the eye and we can slip this
sheet behind the retina and hopefully
these cells will integrate with the rest
of the tissue so this now are these
sheets seeded with these cells and one
of the neat things that we do we have to
know what happens to these cells when we
transplant them so to make them
different from the set from the hosts
that we transplant them into we take
these cells from animals that are green
so that the cells are green and we can
look for the green cells and find out
which cells are the ones we transplanted
so it also makes it easy to get cool
pictures so we put the cells on and
after a few days these cells grow up
really nicely on the scaffold and
actually what we see is that when we
transplant this after 14 days the cells
are still here this is the first time we
saw cells at 14 days after
transplantation before this it was only
maybe one or two percent of the self
that survived so there's something about
giving them a structure that makes them
want to survive better and we're still
trying to understand what it is about
that structure that's attractive to the
cells that they can really survive and
actually start integrating with the
tissue
you and so we wanted to now look at how
they integrate so we take the tissue and
we stain it for different markers and we
use markers that normal healthy cells
should Express and the thing that we
found was all of these progenitor cells
these magic cells they're supposed to
make photoreceptors didn't really have
any markers for any of the
photoreceptors so you can see you'll see
wherever we have arrows here that's
really where we're seeing these markers
for these cells and there aren't very
many arrows because basically our cells
don't seem to want to become
photoreceptors in large numbers a few of
them start to Express markers but
basically they're all still sitting
there they're surviving but they're not
becoming tissue yet so we need to figure
out how to signal to these cells to
actually become photoreceptors say to
them okay now you're in there
everything's great start to
differentiate that's the term we use for
when they start to become the more
mature tissue so we also have done
similar kinds of things in the spinal
cord and the spinal cord is one of the
things that actually my lab is deeply
interested in now the structure of the
spinal cord is very complex but one of
the neat things about being an engineer
is you don't tend to get too worried
about the details so while there's all
these complex tracks that do very
special things as an engineer I looked
at this and said oh so it's two parts
you have a central section here which we
call the gray matter and that's where
all the cell bodies lie so that's where
all the neurons basically and all their
supporting cells are and then you have
this outer section which is called the
white matter because if you actually
look at the tissue it's white and that's
because that's where all those axons are
and the insulation is what makes that
tissue look white so on the outside here
on the outside here you've got long
tracks of axons running up and down
through your spinal cord and on the
inside you've got those cells now I need
to mention some of this but just to
remind you there are 10,000 new injuries
each year in the US and the median age
and injury is only 26 years old medical
technology has improved to the point
where survival is reasonably good after
spinal cord injury but there really
aren't effective treatments that lead to
improved functional recovery after the
injury
now when you have a spinal cord injury
you have a bunch of different things
that happens a lot of times you'll
either severa jour damage those axons
again that's the wires that are running
through the spinal cord you lose that
insulation on the axons and as you can
imagine just like in your house the
wires don't work as well when they're
not insulated the same thing happens in
the spinal cord and you'll also just
lose the cells entirely so our question
was could we actually maybe regrow axons
and replace the cells that are lost so
again being a good engineer and seeing
the spinal cord is just two parts we
basically wanted to create a scaffold
that had two parts so the architecture
of the scaffold mimics the architecture
of the spinal cord and this is what we
came up with now this was going to be
done in a Hemi section model so this is
where only half of the spinal cord is
missing so we actually again this is
just a salt leech sponge like you all
saw made earlier and then we took
another scaffold that has oriented
channels the salt leech sponge was going
to be seated with neural progenitor
cells so these are like neural stem
cells a little bit more mature than
learned neural stem cells and again
these are Mouse cells that we use and we
use these because we can't just take
neurons and put them in there they won't
survive if you take out neurons and try
to get them back in they'll just die but
the progenitor cells don't die so at
least it gave us a chance to see can we
actually replace cells and if we do is
it helpful so we put these progenitor
cells on the inside in the salt leach
scaffold and the outside was designed so
that hopefully axons could regrow along
that and it's tied together here with a
piece of degradable suture material so
if any of you have ever gotten stitches
that dissolved this is that same
material and this dissolving stitch
through material is actually what we're
making all of our scaffolds out of it's
the same kind of stuff so basically we
created an injury and we either did the
treatment with the cells plus the
scaffold or the scaffold alone or the
cells alone or just the tree or just the
injury so that we could see what
actually happens and this is an animal
from the injury group so this animal has
the injury but no other treatment other
than the standard stuff so what you can
see is it doesn't have weight bearing
stepping that's what we call it it's
Peter behind it it can move them which
is really nice but it can't actually
support itself on them and walk in the
traditional way and you can also see
that the feet are in the sort of cramped
position and that's very classic after
these kinds of injuries what's that okay
well they almost got a motor on for a
little bit here so you can see the
animal is also quite curious as they
often are there are always investigating
things so usually looking for snacks it
turns out one of their favourite fruits
foods is fruit loops so this now is the
treatment so it's gotten the scaffold
seated with these progenitor cells and
the big difference is that it actually
has this weight bearing stepping that's
what we're really looking for so it's
lifted up now on its hind legs now one
of the other things we look for is to
see how those hind limbs coordinate with
the front limbs and it doesn't have very
much coordination so it's far from a
perfect animal but at least it has a
major and significant recovery now this
is how we try to quantify that as a
scientist one of the biggest things we
have to do is yeah we can see something
we can think great oh that's fabulous
but we have to be able to quantify it to
know is the difference actually big or
is the difference small so we use a
scale and it's called the BBB scale is
named after the people that developed it
and basically the scale runs from 0 to
21 and what you can see is our scaffold
plus cells is basically coming out of a
12 when it finally when the animals are
fully recovered so it's far from
complete recovery if it were complete it
would be at 21 but it's got that weight
bearing stepping which is why it's a 12
now the lesion the one where it just has
the injury and the cells alone are
completely identical so it turns out in
our hands the neural progenitor cells
did not improve recovery
what did improve recovery is having a
scaffold in place and actually even
though these two lines look different
the pink line and the green line
mathematically it turns out those lines
are essential
the same so when it comes down to is
they're basically even though we have
four groups we really only can see
differences two major differences either
you have a scaffold or you don't have a
scaffold so that means the polymer
scaffold itself is doing a lot to help
recovery happen now the question is then
will what's the polymer scaffold doing
if our progenitor cells really aren't
contributing to recovery very much and
the polymer is why what's actually
happening and what we can do is we can
then look at the tissue and understand
what's happened to the tissue itself we
know that the tissue correlates with the
function and what we see is in lesion
control animals
there's degeneration of the tissue so
the tissue we remove a section of tissue
and what's actually happening is the
tissue around it is falling apart over
time and in fact the other thing we see
is we also often see a lot of scar
tissue so not only is the tissue falling
apart but we're actually getting stuff
in there that we don't want scar tissue
is not going to be functional when we
have the scaffold in place the tissue
doesn't fall apart as much and actually
instead of having the scar tissue we
often have much more normal tissue in
place one of the things that often
happens in the spinal cord after an
injury is the tissue starts to
degenerate and there are a lot of
different things that are associated
with that the in growth of certain kinds
of cells is associated with that
degeneration as well as hemorrhaging and
we think our scaffold helps do things
like stop the hemorrhaging of the tissue
and help inhibit the bad kinds of cells
that grow in those that make scar tissue
and by inhibiting the scar tissue it
creates an environment where the rest of
the tissue can actually heal now the
question is back to these progenitor
cells these essentially stem cells what
are they actually doing why didn't they
contribute to recovery they're supposed
to be magic cells well it turns out that
these cells are basically they're still
there they've survived to the end of the
time course so we do find the cells but
the cells never actually differentiate
it just like we saw in the retina the
stem cells actually a remaining stem
cell so they're not becoming neurons and
they're not becoming the supporting
cells they're just sort of sitting there
so if we do want to use them if we do
think they're useful we're gonna have to
give them some signal just like in the
retina
to get them to actually become mature
functional cells so we still have a lot
of work to do which is unfortunately
pretty common in the field but it keeps
us in business so that's kind of good
now I actually have been motoring on
here with lots and lots of stuff if sort
of blitzkrieg you with a lot of data
that we do in my lab and in other labs
but I just wanted to take a few minutes
and say why be a scientist or engineer
cuz I get asked that a lot
the biggest reason I can see to be a
scientist or engineer is I get to play I
mean instead of being you know added -
just pushing papers I get to be in the
lab and I get to work with my hands and
make neat things either doing the nylon
rope trick which I actually just do to
amuse myself most of the time or getting
to make new things and sometimes when we
make these new things we actually do
something that can make the world a
better place and that is the coolest
feeling in the world when you can really
do something a lot of people also ask me
is it hard to be a scientist or engineer
you know they know that math is hard
science is hard and sometimes it is I
actually struggled with math I I was not
very gifted at it and I spent a lot of
time plugging through things trying to
learn algebra and things like that but
it turns out if you do the work you can
actually do some pretty nifty things
with it and when I finally did learn it
it was good I can now do the kinds of
math that I need to do to do the science
I need to do and I get to have a
phenomenal time every day I get to work
with amazing students and I get to work
with amazing people like Anissa because
of this so if you have any questions I
would love to take them either about the
work or about being a scientist or
anything else so please feel free to ask
right so that's an excellent question
because most injuries the entry happened
a long time ago if we actually want to
try to treat a real clinical person so a
patient we would need to be able to
treat someone who had an injury that's
possibly a long time ago we haven't done
that work yet and the reason for it is
the best chance of success is right
after the entry when the rest of the
tissue is still there you haven't had
all these processes that make the tissue
fall apart now we had what we would
consider exciting results you know the
rats walked but probably what was
happening wasn't that we were growing
lots of new tissue that was functional
it was that we were preserving tissue
and keeping the rest of the tissue from
falling apart so that wouldn't be
helpful at this point but what we did
learn was the scaffold itself is a good
template so if we can add the right
stuff to the scaffold for instance
during development when your spinal cord
is growing there's a lot of chemicals
that are released that tell the spinal
cord how to grow we can actually take
those chemicals and build them into the
scaffold so they're released just like
its released in development and our hope
is that that will help signal to the
spinal cord to start repairing itself so
that's actually what we're looking at
now if that works that would be a really
neat thing to try then in a more
clinically relevant injury where the
injury happened a long time ago
uh-huh so
so it's called a Hemi section model and
basically what happens is a surgeon goes
in you have to get all the approvals for
this and everything and we worked with a
surgeon who is used to doing spinal cord
injury
the surgeon actually goes in and does
what they call lateral Hemi section so
it goes down the midline of the spinal
cord and goes down for about four
millimeters and removes a chunk of
tissue and then puts in the SCAF order
just closes it up so it's a very
significant injury a more common injury
that a patient would sustained as a
contusion injury so bruising to the cord
but if you bruise the core it you get a
similar kind of loss of tissue when
you're all set and done unfortunately
right now at least huh I'll start there
quite striking yes so that's actually
right so that's cartilage and there's
two things about that that are pretty
easy your ear doesn't sustain a lot of
weight so you don't have to worry about
this being a really strong piece of
cartilage whereas in your knee your
cartilage has to be very strong and will
stay on your whole body weight coming
down on it the other thing about it is
that what they were really showing there
was if you create a scaffold with a
particular kind of structure to it
you'll actually make a tissue with that
same structure so however you carve your
scaffold or build your scaffold into a
shape that's the shape of the tissue I
have to say that that image is both
interesting sort of disturbing to see a
human ear strapped on the back of an
animal but it really does prove the
point that if you can make the right
kind of scaffold you can make the right
kind of tissue and in fact they went in
clinically after that therefore patients
who had burns and it lost pieces of
tissue they were able to recapitulate
that tissue and the reason they did in
here was there was actually a patient
who is hoping to get a new ear so they
could be you know look more normal
right yeah for what I do it's probably
not for the knurl stuff it's probably
not good one of the things about the
cells that I work with and we mostly
work with these neural and retinal
progenitor cells not necessarily to grow
new tissue but we actually use them a
lot in vitro to find out of our
environments that we create in our
polymers are useful but one of the
things we've learned is these cells
don't like to be basically sheared so
they don't like to go through small
needles and things like that
so the inkjet printing basically kills
our particular cells for other cells
that are a little bit tougher it might
work well it might be a really neat way
to say okay if we're gonna build a
vasculature let's put the cells in the
vascular tert down right here and then
right next to it we'll put the liver
cells down and maybe we can actually
print basically a liver which by the way
I have some liver up here which I've
sort of forgot to point out but I've
made poor Anisa rather ill before we all
started with my various liver parts that
are hanging it these are actually
chicken livers so that I got from the
grocery store on the way over this
morning so you had a question
so the the outer part of the matrix goes
up and down once it's implanted the
inner part basically goes out and that's
because the cells that are in the inner
part have to be able to reach to the
outer part to do things like myelinate
the cells and actually you do have what
we call interneuronal connections you'll
have a neuron in the spinal cord that
connects with one from the brain and so
we wanted to be able to allow those
pathways to happen
so the idea there was actually when they
started that experiment one of the big
questions was okay you can create a
polymer scaffold and you can put cells
on it will it actually if you do that
once it's implanted will it stay looking
like the scaffold will it still have
that structure or will it overtime
reform you know there was some concern
as the scaffold degrades maybe the
tissue instead of looking like an ear
would form a ball now the last thing you
wanted to do was to you know implant
that on someone had already been through
a pretty traumatic injury so they tried
it on the animal to see if it stayed
like any because we really had no data
on it it turns out if it does stay like
an ear you do maintain that architecture
even after the scaffold is completely
gone and once they knew that they were
then able to do the same thing on a
patient